let's go hey warum was ist das denn hier
schon direkt da lächelt jemand glaub wir
finden auf jeden Fall was schade dass
wir keine Burger ma
ja so ein geiles Bild kannst du dir
einfach vorstellen was in meinem Kopf
passiert GU das Bit bei uns in
Deutschland ist die ATS so
ja das ist der Einkauf also ein
kompletter Wagen voll und es ist kein
günstiges Zeug was wir gekauft haben
deshalb schätze ich
580$ ich habe jetzt nicht gesehen was du
noch alles reingemacht aber darf ich
drüber da drunter sagen okay wir sind
drunter schauen wir mal Eric was sagst
du 460 ach ja so schnell gibt man 500$
aus Freunde herzlich willkommen in
losost Angeles und ich bin hier nicht
allein sondern ich bin tatsächlich mit
Bernt hier gelandet es hat geklappt
unglaublich es ist wirklich einfach
Zufall dass wir hier gemeinsam stehen
okay wir haben uns verabredet aber es
war Zufall dass wir zur gleichen Zeit in
Amerika in LA waren und und wenn ihr
einfach mal hier schaut dann seht ihr
wirklich einen absoluten Traum wir
machen heute eine Barbecue Party wir
sind insgesamt acht Leute und Bern und
ich haben uns gesagt wir machen hier mal
was schönes zu essen du kannst ja schon
mal ein bisschen sagen was wir alles
haben und was wir vorhen e also Barbecue
Party ne also man muss schon mal sagen
es ist ja wirklich schwer sich zu
bremsen auch beim Einkaufen ne also es
ist ja wie so ich fühle mich immer wie
ein kleiner BU beim spielzeugladenf ne
also Hummer Rip eye Bacon wir machen
natürlich hier so ein bisschen Mac and
cheese klarer Fall das ist ja so dein
signature c and cheese ne ich mag sehr
gerne wir machen creamed corn und den
hum machen wir nicht irgendwie sondern
in einer Lobster Roll also es gibt
wirklich einiges was richtig richtig
lecker ist was am allerlängsten dauert
die richen dicker papa macht seine
signature die fast RPS quasi ja kann man
auf jeden Fall runterbrechen braucht
aber immer noch ZHB Stunden geht nicht
anders sollen wir direkt anfangen einm
raus zum Grill gehen ich begleite dich
will dir genau zuschauen bei dem was du
muss noch Kleinigkeit vorbereiten es
muss noch die Silberhaut runtergezogen
werden den Jungs ganz geiler Trick ist
immer den hat man mittlerweile auch
schon h mal gesehen so so ein Trick ist
das gar nicht mehr man geht hier auf den
Knochen einfach mal versucht hier mitm
Löffel drunter zu gehen das jetzt ein
runter Löffel das ist nicht so ganz so
gut geeignet dafür das geht schon das
geht schon ich fange hier drüben schon
mal an wir machen wie gesagt auch
creamcn das ist einfach frischer Mais
mit ganz viel Sahne ein bisschen Zwiebel
ein bisschen Butter und der wird am Ende
einfach nur himmlisch sein deshalb ich
schneide hier mal ein bisschen von
unseren Maiskolben quasi die Körner
runter dann macht da drüben seinen Spaß
und dann haben wir auch schon die Hälfte
vorbereitet heute auf jeden Fall
Silberhaut runter jetzt gibt's ein
bisschen R oben drauf ich habe hier
Kansas City inspired seasoning R sweet
and smoky nicht so scharf ne weil weiß
ich nicht so das S so richen die dürfen
für mich gerne so süß klebrig sein
schmatzig soll sein mit barbecuoße drauf
und so auf jeden Fall verschwenderisch
viel R oben drauf das ist auch so ein
Geheimnis Geheimnis von Barbecue dass
man einfach übertreibt mit Gewürz man
muss es leider übertreiben viel hilft
viel in dem Fall hier insbesondere wenn
es schnell gehen muss das sieht schon
geil aus und vor allem wenn man jetzt so
ein bisschen liegen lässt fangen die
also guck mal du siehst die schon die
fangen an zu schwitzen weil da Salz mit
drin ist ja ja und das ist genau das was
du willst so Grill ist vorgeheizt Hände
werden gewaschen dann gehen wir raus und
dann geben wir den einmal ganz kurz ein
bisschen Hitze mit okay J draußen am
Grill angekommen also der ist schon
richtig hochgeheizt der hat hier ja um
die 300° jetzt am Deckel so guck das mal
an das schon richtig fett schön die
kriegen jetzt erstmal auf der Hautseite
so richtig kurz schön ein mit das heißt
wir haben schon ein bisschen röstum dann
haben wir schon mal außenrum so ein
bisschen ja wie soll ich sagen da tritt
nicht mehr so viel Fleischsaft aus ne
wenn man so die Oberfläche ein bisschen
versiegelt hat das war jetzt das Ziel
die kann ich jetzt auch gleich runter
nehmen und dann ja dann gehen sie in
Backofen einiges schneiden später haben
wir den gesamten Mais hier einmal drin
man kann natürlich ne wenn ihr das zu
Hause nachmachen wollt auch den mais aus
der Dose nehmen funktioniert auch aber
der ist ein bisschen nasser und mit
diesem frischen ist es einfach noch mal
anders war mir klar wenn das im
Augenwinkel auftaucht ne dass du hier
mal kurz rüber guckst da haben wir schon
alles was wir brauchen siehst du das wir
haben die richen hier richtig in Stress
versetzt jetzt ne mit der Hitze du
siehst die bluten aus dem Knochen raus
quasi ne das genau das was ich sehen W W
das für mich der Zeitpunkt wo ich sag
okay jetzt haben sie genug und jetzt
können wir Sie weiter behandeln jetzt
sind die in so einer Aluform hier drin
was wir jetzt machen bisschen abelsaft
drauf au einfach oben drüber den apfelag
ich versuch i unten drunter zu gießen
damit wir jetzt nicht den ganzen R
runter kochen da weiß du und ich ma mir
auch so ein bisschen was von meiner
lieblingsbbecuoße oben drauf da woll
noch jemanden grüßen hast du gesagt
Grüße gehen raus an Otto an der Stelle
der mir eine Galone von dieser sweet by
Barbecue Soße geschenkt hat auch
ordentlich draufhauen
ne
wichtig ist jetzt dass wir das hier mit
der Alufolie so dicht wie möglich
bekommen weil das ist quasi wie wenn
Deckel auf Topf machst ne oder auf de
breter oder so ist auf 320° Fahrenheit
das sind
160 160 Celsius einfach reinstellen
jetzt geht's aber weiter mit dem
creamcorn ich habe hier vorne alles
geschnibbelt dazu noch eine Zwiebel und
das ist einfach ein Traum ne dieser
Stick of butter so das hast du immer in
irgendwelchen Rezepten stehen und jetzt
hat man einfach wirklich diesen
vorverpackten Block Butter wie viel
Gramm sind das keine Ahnung ich geb ein
mal direkt rein die schmilzen hier ein
bisschen und dann gebe ich auch schon
einfach meine Zwiebeln dazu und SP dann
neben dem SP Geruch hält uns hier gar
nichts mehr das duftet einfach alles nur
noch köstlich und wir sollten auch
eigentlich dann schon mal anfangen an
dener zu denken ne da werde ich auf
jeden Fall auch gleich noch bisschen was
zurecht schnppeln ja lobstertes nehme
ich mir habe ich lange nicht gemacht
einmal habe ich das gemacht setzt man
hier unten glaube ich einfach an und
dann einmal hoch zack kräftig drauf was
ich auch gelernt habe ist dass man die
ein bisschen vorlockert mit so einem
Löffel genau dann hast du sie später
beim Grillen einfach kriegst du so
einfach raus gehst einmal rein löst das
ein bisschen und das machen wir jetzt
einfach mit allen lobsters so die
Zwiebeln sind ein bisschen glasiert und
jetzt geben wir unseren Mais hinzu der
Mais köchelt vor sich hin wir gehen mal
mit ein bisschen Salz dran Salz Pfeffer
schon mal so hier vorne ma ich einmal
eben an wird noch heute häufiger
vorkommen weiterck geh wir mal ein Stick
Butter hin wir machen nämlich jetzt eben
eine schnelle Kräuterbutter heavy cream
heißt zu deutsch einfach Kochsahne
glaube ich Schlagsahne tatsächlich ja so
also einfach ordentlich Sahne drauf wir
haben sogar noch eine zweite Flasche
Sahne die wir übrig haben falls uns das
gleich ein bisschen zu dick wird zu zähl
wird aber jetzt erstmal durchrühren und
abwarten so so deine Butter ist hier
auch schon soll ich h schon mal ein
bisschen was RE von dem kN hau ger die
Kräuter rein schön feingeschnittener
Knobi Petersilie bisymian ja hält du es
kurz im Blick weil ich geh jetzt raus
perfekt perfekt ich bin bisschen
aufgeregt sage ich dir ganz ehrlich ich
habe nich Angst um den Hummer ich will
dass das alles funktioniert ALR Leute
Grill ist schön heiß ich habe mich
gerade mit Bern besprochen wir legen
jetzt unseren Hummer einmal schön hier
auf mit mit der Schale nach unten und
dann du kannst das ja schon mal machen
Pinseln
wir lass den hier noch mal schön warm
werden bepinseln wir ein wenig mit der
Butter es ist wirklich einfach ein Traum
also so viel Hummer auf einer Stelle
habe ich selten gesehen glaube
ich ungefähr 5 Minuten später sehen
unsere humerschwänze wie folgt aus
richtig schön jetzt haben sie auch diese
orange rote Farbe bekommen die man von
Hummer kennt das kommt nämlich immer
erst nach dem Garen jetzt holen wir sie
raus sehr schonende Methode auch ne ja
weil indirekt halt eigentlich ne so
Freunde so sieht der Hummer aus wenn er
fertig ist und wir haben uns schon mal
hier was vorbereitet als kleine
Qualitätskontrolle kommt wirklich
perfekt raus einfach und dann Vorarbeit
lohnt sich dann einfach auch ne
schmecken me lieber so machen wir das
hier
geil kommt super wirklich zuckersüß und
der Tymian mit der Süße ist wirklich
perfekt wir holen jetzt aber raus und
dann machen wir noch mal unsere Soße
fertig das hier ist alles was von
unseren humerschwänzen übrig geblieben
ist wenn man mal Hummer gegessen hat
dann weiß man dass das auf jeden Fall
der Teil ist wo am allermeisten Fleisch
drin steckt und das schneide ich jetzt
einfach einmal hier so grob runter wir
machen jetzt aber folgendes wir haben
hier unsere geschmolzene Butter einfach
Mayonnaise rein in die Butter und dann
ordentlich
rüberu noch ein bisschen Limette sehr
schön und jetzt Hummer rein in unsere
Schale es ist ja Wirich sehr pervers und
sehr amerikanisch was wir damit machen
ich sehe schon was wir da brauchen fast
alles
zack es ist pervers ne also sowas mit
dem Hummer zu machen ist einfach krass
aber wir sind hier in Amerika ne lster
auf jedem Restaurant auf der Karte wir
machen jetzt folgendes wir machen uns
wirklich max einfach wir nehmen uns
unsere hotlockband wie die sind fluffig
weil die Teile Kings way sind wirklich
geisteskrank es gibt ein Laden hier in
Los Angeles die verwenden die als
burgerband und die sind einfach geil
also die sehen auch schon sexy aus mus
wir öffnen uns hier unser Bann es ist
wirklich einfach ein bisschen pervers
finde ich ne so diesen Hummer in dieses
kalte Bann zu tun aber es ist so schön
weich und so
fluffig das ist sie unsere Lobster Roll
K wahrscheinlich 40er hier wasan ja und
wir haben sie selbst gemacht war ein
bisschen Arbeit aber ich glaube die
dürfen wir uns schmecken lassen werden
wir probieren komm direkt rein ich ma
mir auch eine ferig sagst
du manchmal sage ich einfach g Du was
ich meine rein die Süße und dieser
Hotdog Roll ich find wirklich perfekt
geht sich sehr gut zusammen aus wirklich
ich bin halfoh dass wir das gemacht
haben ja einfach geil und das ja das
Schöne wir warten jetzt quasi auf den
Hauptgang haben schon ein paar Sachen
vorbereitet und dann gleich geht es
wirklich mit dem Star des Tages mit Bern
spips weiter wir machen Mac and cheese
und ich habe ein Rezept von kiop das ist
einfach klassisch das ist Legende das
benötigt nur drei Zutaten und zwar
natürlich die altbekannten elbow
Macaroni also diese gebogenen makaroni
dann Käse worauf man Lust hat wir nehmen
cheddder und Kondensmilch aber ungesüßt
also quasi auf Englisch heißt das
evaporated milk also einfach Milch die
runtergekocht wurde amtliche Menge ne
aber wie wie gesagt es ist wirklich eine
amtliche Menge aber wir sind noch eine
Weile hier und dann haben wir ein
bisschen MEC and cheese oder einfach in
Topf
geben Zack und das jetzt dass es gerade
so mit Wasser bedeckt ist okay wir
kochen das jetzt so dass quasi am Ende
vom Kochen die Nudeln gar sind und das
Wasser komplett verkocht
istode quasi dann schütten wir die Milch
drauf bringen das zum Kochen und Salzen
einmal so das Wasser kocht ihr seht es
aber nicht mehr weil die Nudeln schon
leicht aufgekollen sind wir kochen das
jetzt so lange bis das Wasser quasi
komplett verkocht ist und der Trick
daran ist auch dass man dadurch dass man
nur das Wasser verwendet auch die ganze
Stärke drin behält unser Wasser ist
verkocht jetzt geben wir einfach die
Kondensmilch oben drauf einfach
reinschüten
zackah jetzt haben wir den Käse rein yes
Baby ja also geb ich mir einfach ich ich
rühre okay du rührst das ist mal so ein
Riesel oder
genau man merkt jetzt wirklich jetzt
beginnt und wir kriegen diese
wunderschöne Textur langsam aber sicher
haben aber noch ein bisschen Käse übrig
es ist einfach geil ja wir haben
eigentlich alles fertig Steaks machen
wir noch fertig RS machen wir fertig die
H ich jetzt raus bin ich
gespannt wie das DFT ja dann ma mal auf
ich bin echt gespannt was wir jetzt
darin
sehen so soll sein mal stark schon
direkt sehe dass der Garpunkt gut ist
wenn das Fleisch sich schon Knochen
zurückzieht was wir jetzt machen wir
drehen sie um direk en rein dann haben
wir den Grill gleich fertig und schön
sauber und ordentlich für die Steaks so
erstmal umdrehen wirklich wenn ihr
riechen könntet wie das duftet so wenn
man an sparips denkt dann riecht man
genau das so was wir jetzt machenil wirü
ein bisschen was von der Gleis zusammen
und zwar geben wir einfach ein bisschen
was von dem was hier unten ist ah geil
hier vorne rein
rein alles was wir brauchen das ist
jetzt im Prinzip Fleischsaft Apfelsaft
und halt Ex und Barbe ja genau so jetzt
gehen wir her und dann füllen wir das
hier auf
mit reichlich Barbecue sweet baby Ray ja
und von dir hätte ich gerne noch so ein
bisschen Honig hier rein bitte mein mein
Bärchen einfach bisschen von dem
granulierten Knoblauch noch mit dran
wenn der gleich warm wird lässt i
einfach eine schöne Knoblauchnote noch
da man darf nicht übertreiben mit dem
getrockneten Zeug finde ich aber im
Barbecue ist es einfach immer gut das
hat's in sich ne ja voll voll voll so
was jetzt kommt einali das ist ein glaze
genau richtig und du wirst sehen was
gleich im Ofen damit passiert wir lassen
die Temperatur jetzt auch immer so bei
stehen das duftet ne und es trocknet wir
holen jetzt raus und dann lieren wir
noch
mal gleiche Geschichte von vorne gleiche
Geschichte von vorne top top top und
wieder rein mit euch quasi die gesamte
Zeit die unsere SPS gebraucht haben hat
unser cream corn auf dem Herd gesessen
eine wunderschöne Konsistenz jetzt geben
wir fürs Auge noch mal ein bisschen pas
mit rein für die frischeer auch
natürlich genau rühren das unter dann
hat man diese kleinen Stücke drin und
wer das nicht kennt muss es mal machen
es ist einfach es ist einfach geil hier
haben wir unsere Steaks und wir machen
damit jetzt genau das was wir immer mit
unseren Steaks machen von allen Seiten
bisschen mit Olivenöl einmassieren dann
Salz drauf Knoblauchpulver drauf und
dann ist es auch schon ready ja wir
haben auf der linken Seite jetzt die
Brenner auf Vollgas rechts ist aus ne
damit wir so ein indirekten Bereich
haben gleich aber wir geben den schon
ordentlich ne so z D Minuten pro Seite
brauchen man jetzt echt Geduld haben ne
bei einem guten Steak absolut hab ich
gelernt einfach warten schauen wir uns
die Steaks mal an es sieht wirklich
einfach jetzt schon traumhaft aus noch
mal kurz warten jo und dann schauen wir
mal wie es aussieht und jetzt wenden wir
unsere steakes einmal oh jetzt oh schöne
Farbe dran bekommen und das zerfällt
jetzt schon fast jetzt ist die andere
Seite dran und dann sind sie eigentlich
auch schon fertig wir sehen uns gleich
beim Probieren
[Musik]
wieder Freunde das sieht doch wirklich
fantastisch aus das was wir jetzt gerade
hier haben das ist einfach nur hübsch
und man greift automatisch zu diesem
Steak ne das steck ist so hübsch
geworden hat paar Minuten nur gedauert
aber so ein US Beef man wird auch immer
wieder belohnt einfach ne ja genauso
aber wir haben dieses salzige würzige
Steak dieser creamcn also die Konsistenz
ist aber auch Wahnsinn es ist wirklich
was besonderes ne es riecht so schön
karamellig auch
ne und der bis der halt noch da ist ne
klare Sache and cheese
weiß du davon kannst du nicht mega viel
Essen einfach kines Topping ja genau
aber was Du hier gezaubert hast Bern das
möchte ich unbedingt probieren h das
Highlight die bekannten Bern zer papchen
so soll sein so wir gemacht
probier mit dem Biss vom
knochenelut kann auch ist wirklich sehr
sehr lecker W Freunde ich ihr hat
lasst gerne ein Like da schaut unbedingt
bei wen vorbei Abo da lassen damit ihr
es nicht verpasst und bis zum nächsten
Mal macht's gut vielen Dank tschüss ich
hab noch eine Sache schreibt doch mal
gerne in die Kommentare wer von euch die
Küche hier sauber machen möchte